I have a boyfriend
why I'm shaking him hold its up
quivering which more director immense
over you lectures I read just put your
help oh I'm sorry I do it because it's a
cherry picker
I have like white people right out of
here like or something like like whether
they gotta lay off hey I want to go to
this so what about now oh here what
about now what about now yeah we got
some [ __ ] rubbish
hey speaking of this again videos and
definite red and brown Oh me I like cars
like I like my girls fast and full again
that's the tool again it's like a mud
river it's like a muddy river ever done
the Tough Mudder through soap
Oh button sexy rolls everywhere
[Laughter]
85% a cat 85% to counter jungle I'm good
I feel one comment I feel one corner
it'll wash girls I could kill you ah
[Music]
I'll do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
cold kissing oh geez what you know I
guess it was going the wrong way
Oh pinch it just the hedge will nobody
no no no we're doing this now shoot
ready ready right ready I totally get it
it connects with my hand here absolute
move it
yeah where do you want to go on my head
on your head head yes okay here we go
all right show you right should I put
out my face now okay you ready for this
one second attempt to go okay me second
like I'm shaking mm-hmm
I'm sorry I get weird about spiders you
all are on my favorite girl result why
did feel an archer hmm you guys know
we're now now
[Music]
you